hey guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
gucci mane the title of the song is
[ __ ] crazy as you know
i don't really watch rap music i don't
really i don't really listen to it
outside of this channel so
i'm gonna take you with me through my
interpretation of this song
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
also follow me on instagram because i do
suggestions for what songs i should
react to like each week so if you want
to be a part of that follow me on
instagram
um i think that's everything i need in
my intro
right i should really write this down
someday
okay i'm gonna make this big
okay
okay i already like this beat
bop in the head little shimmy little
shimmy
not a big shimmy [ __ ] okay
[Music]
okay just to summarize he's just saying
like i'm famous and i got money i ain't
losing sleep about it though
members creep like tlc two to three
shells out
no one gonna take care of me the way
that i take care of me
[Music]
so he's saying nobody's going to take
care of me like i take care of me
that just means that you got to take
care of yourself
and you can't rely on other people and
that's a good message
a very nice wholesome message i'd also
like to say i like the color
in his outfit i think it makes like the
video pop
you know put your friend in there
i don't play detectives
i think that he's basically just
reiterating that i have money
thing um
so since the guy's name is gucci mane so
when he says like i got
gucci i think of the bag but like is
he's talking about his friend
i think he's still talking about the bag
[Music]
okay so he's talking about how snitching
is a bad thing and i guess
the maybe the opposition or some other
guys were like
telling their mom to snitch on him and
that's not a good way if you're gonna
snitch
that's not the way to do it
we drove 14 hours from mifflin with dope
and some glitter
so he drove 14 out hours with dope
so like drugs and some gliss glizzy
i think that's a gun he did the this
sign i'm assuming that's a gun
um so they're into some illegal
activities
[Music]
okay
i am going to give this song
7.5 out of 10. i thoroughly enjoyed the
beat like honestly
like you guys saw me i was shimmying a
little bit like
bopping my head i really liked the beat
what i didn't appreciate
i'm not a fan of like throwing your
money in people's faces i think it's
better to be humble
however i think that's a lot of rap
music i'm not gonna lie to you so
i'm not gonna hate on like if that's how
it is let me know
in the comments do you agree do you
disagree or like what do you think i got
right what do you think i got wrong
and what do you think i should react to
next time
i'm gonna talk to you guys later yeah
later